Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has pulled
a disgusting political stunt that
actually isn't that terrible for some of
the people involved and I'll explain
that in a moment but the big headline is
that Ron DeSantis flew 50 migrants to
the Swanky island of Martha's Vineyard
and this is really just a sick political
stunt it's meant to trigger and own the
libs and on and on and on but I'm going
to argue that this is actually quite the
opposite a Business Insider has a report
about this DeSantis sent 50 migrants to
Martha's Vineyard by plane as an
anti-liberal stunt the locals pulled
together to help them now I I've spent a
lot of time on Martha's Vineyard and as
soon as I saw the headlines my instinct
was
I don't know that this is going to work
out necessarily the way Ron DeSantis
imagines it working out because Martha's
Vineyard is very very liberal
extraordinarily liberal and it only
follows logically that you are going to
see the people of Martha's Vineyard come
together to help these 50 individuals as
The Story Goes Governor this is Business
Insider Governor Ron DeSantis of Florida
sent plain loads of migrants to Martha's
Vineyard in Massachusetts it was
apparently intended to shift some of the
burden of migration to a rich liberal
area
locals at the exclusive destination
where Barack Obama owns property rallied
to help out
state senator Julian sear of
Massachusetts told the New York Times
about 50 migrants arrived in two planes
with no warning Fox News digital
reported the story and had video of
migrants disembarking from Planes all
right you can imagine what it looks like
for people to get off of a plane yes
Florida can confirm the two planes with
illegal immigrants that arrived in
Martha's Vineyard today were part of the
state's relocation program to transport
illegal immigrants to Sanctuary
destinations that's teren fenske the
comms director for DeSantis and then you
just have to look at the reaction from
the island of Martha's Vineyard Dylan
Fernandez posting our Island jumped into
action putting together 50 beds giving
everyone a good meal providing a play
area for the children making sure people
have the health care and support they
need we are a community that comes
together to support immigrants
um another article from CBS Florida's
DeSantis flies dozens of illegal
immigrants to Martha's Vineyard
escalating tactic against quote
Sanctuary destinations think about how
absurd this is first of all Florida
spends a bunch of money to fly people
out
these folks appear to actually have come
from Texas not even from Florida so it's
like why is Rhonda sandis even involved
why is taxpayer money being spent to
move people from Texas to Massachusetts
that doesn't even make sense first and
foremost secondly from a fiscal
conservatism point of view I think it
would have been cheaper for Florida to
set up temporary housing and vocational
training for these folks eventually
making them a productive tax paying
component of the Florida economy rather
than just blowing a few million dollars
of taxpayer money to fly people from
Texas to Massachusetts for a political
stunt and by the way if these folks
eventually want to go back to Texas
they're going to be able to do it and
nothing's going to stop them and Ron
DeSantis isn't going to track them down
and fly them out again so it's not only
absurd sort of superficially
but it doesn't even make sense in terms
of a political stunt with taxpayer money
now in the meantime the the migrants are
now in Martha's Vineyard rather than
Florida or Texas and statistically
without casting any aspersions or
judgment without making any moral
statement if you look at the HDI that's
the human development index of
Massachusetts Florida and Texas which is
a metric that considers a number of
different types of well-being the
migrants are certainly far better off in
Massachusetts than they would be in
Florida or Texas but that's sort of a
different story and then the last kind
of uh absurd or ironic component of this
is that when Ron DeSantis pulls these
stunts and sends people from Red states
to Blue States or when Abbott Greg
Abbott the governor of Texas Republican
has also pulled these types of stunts
before
aren't you incentivizing immigration
because you're sending the signal to
migrants
undocumented immigration that would be
you're sending the signal to migrants
Hey listen
even if where you would manage to get is
Texas which I mean you know just look at
the data Texas is no it's no Beauty when
it comes to access to health care
education quality all these different
things
you get yourself the taxes we'll get you
to a much better state by most metrics
by pulling this stun you're arguably
incentivizing the very undocumented
immigration that you want to disincent
device by saying we'll upgrade you to a
state with higher income more Access to
Health Care better infrastructure and
better education they claim to want to
disincentivize that very undocumented
immigration it's a pathetic stunt I
don't know what this does to public
opinion to an empirical question we have
to wait and see but by every metric we
can measure a very stupid stunt let me
know your thoughts maybe I'm missing
something find me on Twitter at dpacman
also remember that Monday 9 19 just four
days away we are doing our blowout
historic membership special you've been
thinking of becoming a member this is a
perfect time to do it get on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com and then
Monday morning you will get a perfect
email telling you exactly how to Avail
yourself of this great membership
discount
the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent deep sleep
is lowering your core body temperature
when your body stays cooler at night
you're more comfortable and your sleep
is better our sponsor sleep me is the
home of chili sleep the customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions that
can improve your sleep by keeping you
cooler at night there are three
different chili sleep systems there's
the uler the cube and the new Doc Pro
with double the cooling power all three
systems are water-based temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
you with your ideal sleep temperature
you can go as cool as 55 degrees you can
go really hot if you want I keep mine at
60. beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night